hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 16 video is kind of
like part 2 of episode 15 but it was
really a rogue episode main attraction
being golden glider a cape you know or
Payton list from The Tomorrow People I
know we're all really hoping that Robbie
Amell is gonna get starred in the same
episode that she gets stars in next time
the Rogues are rumored to be coming back
later this season
I think it's episode 21 but I'll talk
about that after I get through episode
16 stuff hands down one of the most
quotable episodes of the flash so far
and in case you guys didn't know the
person that wrote this episode Kai Wu is
the same person that's writing the flash
season zero comic book she's like the
resident rogue expert on the flash staff
right now so I'm looking forward to her
coming back and season two and writing a
whole bunch more rogue episodes and
bringing some new drugs on the show I
know everyone wants to see mirror master
but careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five berry explains to Harrison wells
that he ruptured the time continuum I
like Tom Cavanaugh's line temporal
reversion you have to kind of bite your
lip every time the reverse-flash talks
about the dangers of time travel just
because that's all he does as time
travel it's the pot calling the kettle
black and I know everyone's asking about
black racer that wasn't him at the end
of the episode but I'll explain that
later in the video
hands down my favorite quote from the
episode though was when well said
whatever tragedy you think you avoided
time will find a way to replace it last
week we learned a Oh bard dawn is trying
to get back to his own time we don't
know exactly what his grand plan is
other than getting back we don't know if
he's trying to save his dead wife if he
was lying about her I don't think he was
because he had that big speech about
choosing between two people that you
love it just got way more complicated so
we'll just have to open up a couple more
tabs in chrome for a couple more weeks
also I know everyone's wondering how
they explain time travel in the episode
because there weren't two flashes in the
past it seems like Grant Gustin either
merged with his past itself or it was
like a transfer of consciousness if you
want to get really specific when talking
about time travel a lot of people say
you know physically time-traveling is
impossible scientifically Days of Future
past is slightly more logical based on
our understanding of time and space
right now so let's just say the flash is
going
Days of Future past roles I know it
doesn't explain why Grant Gustin is
punching someone else in a flash costume
just like his it could be another
version of him from the future or the
past or it could be someone masquerading
as him either way for episodes 15 and 16
time travel Days of Future past rolls
that moment where he locked whether was
it up like where he was rushed and right
into the prison that was so scooby-doo I
don't know when we're gonna see him
again on the show but because he
Harrison wells teased the idea of a
cataclysmic level event I think that's
gonna be part of the season finale and
episode 21 is called rogue heir because
it invokes some themes of the elements I
think that whether wizard might be back
in that episode too along with the other
rogues on to number 4 meet Cisco's
brother watching them go out it was so
much fun I it was touching to see them
reconcile by the end of the episode but
I am so happy that the show is taking
the time to build out these other
characters they all come from somewhere
I mean they they have lives outside of
team flash that's a big part of what
makes their characters interesting
learning all about this competitive
relationship with his brother it really
informs Cisco's pathos it gives you an
idea of why he worked so hard I mean yes
he does enjoy it a lot like all the
Slurpees and all the naming villains but
most of the work he does doesn't even
happen on screen like when he was
building the guns that probably took him
a long time to build those onto number
three the robes are back and we get to
meet Captain Cold sister Lisa snart it's
so much fun watching them on screen with
her together that scene with the Santini
mob boss when they didn't have the guns
it was just a show that they're just as
dangerous without the guns as they are
with the guns doesn't Dominic Purcell
performance as heatwave remind you a
little bit of Gorilla Grodd it's just so
much fun to watch him be crazy painless
great actress I'm so happy that she's
part of the flare averse now she did
talk a little bit about her character
before the episode aired
it's just when they were looking to cast
the character of golden glider because
they cast Dominic Purcell and Wentworth
Miller too you know really big actors to
have a lot of experience they wanted an
actress that will be able to go
toe-to-toe with them so you can think of
this version of the golden glider is
closer to the new 52 portrayal slightly
more villainous but I think as we see
the character more we'll learn more
about her history she'll get a little
more sympathetic this was just like the
first taste of golden glider I like that
she thinks of herself as pretty and
toxic what are your intentions with my
sister Sisko
captain cold seems like he's on a
first-name basis with everyone and how
about the scene where she entrapped
Sisko that was so great Carlos the actor
that plays Sisko talked about his
character potentially getting a love
interest in the future I don't think
that he was talking about this scene the
scene in the bar I was wondering how the
Rogues were gonna get their guns back
and I'm kind of glad they did but on to
number two
Barry and Captain Cold strike a bargain
just to start with the big stuff first
this is actually a really important
thing from the comics a really important
aspect of the Rogues rule number one you
never kill a speedster the way they did
it in the episode was just a little
broader no killing anyone but it's a big
comic book reference Captain Cold as the
name implies is the one with the cool
head he usually rains people and where
they get to nuts
heatwave being at the top of that list I
know it seemed like there might have
been something going on with golden
glider and heatwave in the episode but
in the comics she really has more of a
thing going on with mirror master but he
hasn't been brought into the show yet
and finally my number one moment
Harrison wells in Cisco's final scene I
think when it's all said and done Tom
Cavanagh as performance as the
reverse-flash will probably the best
villain of any comic book show are
really any drama period this year the
actor Tom Cavanagh said that when he did
kill Cisco in last week's episode he was
really sad to do it he really does care
for him which is why in this episode
when he said the same lines it was so
touching
consequently when the other shoe drops
and they do find out about Harrison
wells in the season finale it's gonna
make things that much crazier and that
much more fun that dynamics have also
shifted now because Barry's gonna be the
one investigating Harrison wells cisco
is probably gonna back off so here's my
big question for you guys
you know relative to Cisco and the
reverse-flash you know because he said
that you know he would help him in
episode 15 when he thought he was gonna
die and now Harrison wells is kind of
told me you kind of like my son do you
think that Cisco is going to turn
against Barry in the finale something
really big is gonna have to happen for
Cisco to go against Harrison wells now
or aerobar Thawne however you want to
think about him you can still call him
Harrison wells
my second favorite line of the episode
was when actually what Harrison wells
said making a choice between two people
you love that's the hardest dilemma
you'll face he was not lying so I think
the two people that he was referring to
that
and Wells was referring to was his dead
wife and Barry Allen in the comics a Oh
Bart Thawne idolized Barry Allen he was
like his role model his entire life he
didn't even become the reverse-flash
till he went back in time to try and
meet Barry Allen but accidentally ended
up in the flash Museum learned that the
reverse flash was a villain that's what
gave him the first push to become the
reverse-flash
so Harrison wells has to like choose who
gets to live does Barry Allen get to
live or does his wife get to live and
remember all the things that he told
Barry think about how many people might
die if your mother had lived big
flashpoint Easter Egg right there
Andrew Kreisberg actually said that
they're building up to a really big
comic book storyline I at first I
thought it might be flashpoint there are
a number of other things they could do
to like they could try and strip the
reverse-flash of his powers like in
rebirth or any other number of things I
think I mentioned most of the Easter
eggs already like the Rogues bargain
never kill any speedsters I mean I mean
obviously the episode did it a little
bit differently the santini Mob
character he actually appeared in a lot
of Penguins stories a lot a lot of
Batman penguin stories golden glider
obviously a big character in the comic
books one of the big differences between
her character on the show and in the
comics is that she doesn't use a gun in
the new 52 comics she has more of like
an astral projection power in the
classic comics she had like ice skates
that would generate ice that she would
skate all over town on kind of like
Iceman from x-men at the end of the
episode whenever the reverse-flash
killed Irish's coworker he phased his
fist through his chest that's a big
flash move phasing through objects we
haven't seen Barry do it yet but he
probably will before the end of the
season I know a lot of people wondered
if that was the black racer no it was
the reverse-flash it's just you know
part of his uniform has a little bit of
black on it for those that are wondering
in the comics the black racer only
appears when a speedster is getting
ready to die a really good story to read
if you want to read up on the black
racer is just flash rebirth
I mean it's oh it's a really big story
about the return of Barry Allen I would
say if you're if you're looking for
comic book stories for like the big WTF
they might get to like flashpoint or
something from rebirth really just
anything from Geoff Johns run there's
like one Golden Age thing that they
might do that it that involves the
reverse-flash the a Oh Bart Thawne
reverse-flash of Barry Allen but I think
it's going to be something big from
Geoff Johns run don't forget next week's
episode Mark Hamill is back as the James
jesse trick
that's the character that he played in
the original flash TV show it's like the
exact same character just imagine he's
been in prison this whole time be sure
to subscribe to get my video I'll post
it right after the episode airs it's
gonna be so much fun
you have no idea well you guys wait for
that you can click here for last week's
episode and you can click here to learn
all about Wally West's coming on the
show in season 2 thank you so much for
watching now let's all high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow